all signs are pointing to a major panic
at the Democrat disco now it's not just
pundits on MSNBC we starting to worry
about Joe and kamla's staying power
Obama's now put the word out via the
Washington Post and NBC news that he's
concerned about his old number two in a
private lunch that was obviously not
private Obama grew animated in
discussing the election and Trump's
potential return to power he even
suggested to those close to by that the
campaign needs to move aggressively As
Trump appears poised to quickly wrap up
the Republican nomination we're going to
continue to do what we need to do in
order to be competitive and in order to
make sure we're growing the
infrastructure that we need to win one
thing is that we're both aligned on the
fact that we have to push back on magga
extremist and the threat that they pose
to freedom and democracy um and so we're
focused on doing just that okay Obama's
not the only one worried Congressman Jim
kurn who helped deliver South Carolina
for Biden in 2020 he sounding the alarm
well I'm not worried I'm very concerned
I have no problem with the Biden
Administration and what it has done my
problem is that we have not been able to
break through uh that Maga wall in order
to get to people exactly what this
president has done wa the Maga wall
that's a new one now that's funny the
Democrats have what 95% of the press
maybe more all of Academia
and the entire social media world except
act of course X all of the uh Hollywood
they have that so what they're really
upset by is the fact that America is on
to their game and now it's so bad that
the big guys either warning of white
supremacy or at this point is just going
to go
biblical it's the gospel song sayings
we've come too far from where we
started nobody told me the road would be
easy I don't believe you brought me this
far to leave
me my fellow
Americans I don't think the good Lord
brought us this far to leave us
behind oh my gosh joining us now is n
Gingrich former Speaker of the House Fox
News contributor new didn't didn't
Hillary try that she did that I Ain't No
Ways Tired remember she was quoting the
gospel in the waning days of her
campaign trying to get people
out and now G tried in a church in
Pittsburgh in 2000 there are certain
Basics that run through the Democratic
party but I'll I'll tell you what I
think Republicans have to worry about as
the Democrats Panic they're going to
increasingly use the justice department
to literally try to destroy Trump so he
can't compete whether that means
knocking him off the ballot whether it
means locking him up I mean I think the
judge in Washington DC who is a total
radical relishes the the idea of an
excuse to put Trump in chain literally
in Chains uh and I think we should not
underestimate that faced with the break
of everything they believe in and that's
what Trump represents he's an
alternative world where criminals stay
in jail immigrants stay out of the
United States we actually take steps to
be strong again and and their view of
that is that a trump Victory is the end
of their world and I think their
ultimate response is going to come
through the justice department
and is going to be an effort to frankly
with total
unconstitutionality destroy Trump as as
a potential Contender well uh and just
literally lock him up yeah we just
talked about that with Chris landow of
course who was Ambassador to Mexico for
Trump and cler for scal and Thomas and I
think ultimately we're going to see how
good these justices are on the Supreme
Court that were appointed by Republican
presidents we'll see how we'll see how
constitutional they are when these cases
roll up to the court because each and
every one of them is going to end up
getting up there note
look but with all respect I'm a
historian not a lawyer you're an
attorney the people you interview are
attorneys they actually act as though
the law matters what you're dealing with
is a team that believes in the rule of
power not the rule of law and I think
you I don't think we can imagine how
prepared they are to do whatever it
takes to make sure that we can't win
this fall I'm I'm genuinely worried for
the country really for the first time in
my life I think I think you're faced
with a totally corrupt uh radical
ideology that is prepared to in every
way it has to use every element of power
that it's got and frankly with the
federal government the New York state
government the attorney in in in fton
County they have a lot of tools to bring
to bear to try to destroy us because
they're terrified of us with the natural
majority they know it yeah well n at the
same time I think we have to not
demoralize the people out there to think
all hope is lost there's going to be
cheating the election they're going to
cheat cheat well okay then everyone can
just pick up you know their their sticks
and go home I mean I think this is where
you got to you got to make sure that
Republicans run a 50-state campaign and
this has got to be a Reagan style
Landslide for Trump I I I don't think
this could be dabble around in the in
the you know the the the usual states of
the Battleground States I think this has
got to be a campaign for America all
50 no no look I agreee with that
entirely fin only point is we had better
have a strategy all of us who are
activists for what we do if you have a
radical judge in a in a district that
went 19 to1 against Trump with a radical
us attorney deliberately trying to
destroy the election I I I think that's
the great threat I think that Trump will
win I think he'll probably win in a
landslide but notice also your
description of the Senate Republicans
they don't get it the country doesn't
want them selling out to the Democrats
the country wants us to aggressively
stand up for America and take the heat
if necessary your message to the Speaker
of the House on this so-called border
deal new tonight very quickly one line
what's your message to him don't do it
thank you don't do it don't turn it turn
it down all right new great to see you
as always thanks so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else